so
manhattan manhattan
new york okay had a record 15
025 empty apartments
in august ouch let me say this one more
time manhattan had a record of 15 025
empty apartments in august the borough
vacancy
rate rose above 5 for the first time
ever according to a report from real
estate
from douglas element an appraiser miller
samuel it was the highest level in the
report's
14-year history during which manhattan's
vacancy rate
has fluctuated between one and a half
percent
to two and a half percent guys let me
let me say this to you to go from one
and a half to two and a half
to five percent is double this is not a
small number here
over the past four months the rate has
made a steady and steep rise hitting a
record
each month adam you see the stats with
new york
15 025 empty apartments in august
5 vacancy for the first time what do you
think about this
you know if you asked me um in february
so every summer i tend to get out of my
uh born and raised in miami i live in
miami i can work remote
if you ask so every summer i try to go
someplace different i travel what have
you
if you asked me this february
pre-coveted
what my summer plans would be i'd say
there's a hundred percent chance i'll be
in new york chillin i love new york city
you know rent an apartment for a month
or two um
i love it i love just i put on some
headphones and i just walk all around
the city
there's nothing like it in manhattan in
manhattan it's it's it's the bump
um fast forward um um
in in the second city closest to new
york city addison texas is nothing more
bad
i mean it just shows what kovitt has
done it has taken
the life out of new york city i mean
think about why you live in new york
city think about why you pay a premium
to live in new york city and new york
city number two
most expensive place to rent number one
san francisco median rent in new york
for a one bedroom
seven hundred square feet three thousand
dollars right three thousand
unbelievable national average you're
looking at 1400 bucks so double and then
if you're talking that's median actually
average actually closer to four thousand
but you pay a premium for
all the fun and amazing stuff you can do
in new york
the museums the parks the culture going
out to eat
but if you can't do that and you're
sitting at home
why the hell are you paying three four
grand or if not more
to sit in your apartment yeah there's no
point yeah
so you pay a premium premium for
fun and lifestyle but if there's no fun
in lifestyle and you're just sitting at
home
and you can work virtual it's actually a
very good point you're making why would
you ever live in new york at this so so
the benefit that new york offers you're
now not getting so why am i paying that
kind of money to be in new york very
valuable the point of new york
very valid point very valid point what
do you think about that yeah the same
thing too is uh back to culture yeah
that was the
that's the culture of manhattan the
connections and the whole cycle if
if businesses aren't operating to create
the jobs
and the jobs for people to make money
people to spend the money yeah
so business can still thrive so it
doesn't receive the money so that whole
cycle is not happening right now
so if the cycle is not happening this is
exposing this is exposing that
that that vacancy so so this is the
question to ask so when you think about
right now with
nfl game yesterday we were watching
deshaun watson against uh
pat mahomes right shout out to uh uh
mahomes for
you know coming out yeah just doing what
he does and
then deshawn watson you know he he lost
a very good receiver we hope he gets
something back because that guy's a
talented guy but
you know you're watching a game and they
have some fans there they're
expecting 17 000 people in kc yeah a lot
of these nfl stadiums they're not
selling any tickets right but casey said
yes so 17 thousand people showed up
to the game right give or take they
usually have what seventy thousand they
usually have
sixty seventy thousand people there
right so you watch the nba
the bubble right and you see what's
going on with the bubble
and you're watching some of these games
and people watching the games from their
what do you call it their screens then
you know their uh
zoom and like okay cool let me see how
this is going to work
the question you ask with sports is and
restaurants is the following
say because of covid nba lost a million
fans that are watching it i'm just
throwing a number out there
the question you gotta ask is how many
are gonna come back
okay so if you watch football and you
watch and say i'm not interested like i
was before you gotta have the fans the
screaming the hollering oh you know the
richter skill on the sound oh it's so
loud right now
seattle golan you know what seattle is
known to be one of the loudest
oklahoma city is known as being one of
the louder yeah now you don't have that
element right i mean if you're missing
that 12 minutes so
are you going to watch the game the same
way but the question becomes how many
are going to come back
i think the biggest thing with this
manhattan deal is the following
fine you're at 5 yes it's scary
the question is how many are going to
come back right
that's a real question because if it
doesn't
mayor de blasio needs to be fired asap
and cuomo's got to get involved because
one of his mayors is screwing the whole
thing in new york
and comas got to look at what things
he's doing to take some responsibility
and seeing what they need to change in
the state of new york to not be losing
people
and to gain people back because you
remember the whole conversation we had a
few weeks ago
where uh uh the whole thing was well you
know
aoc you know amazon why should we give
you tax breaks to come to new york city
why are we giving these billionaires tax
breaks because they're moving their
entire operation to a place that they're
not used to
and they're going to create 25 000 jobs
at an
average salary of 150 000 for your city
that you lost well now that you're
losing
an audience and your apartments 15 025
are empty
do you want those people back so so
cuomo has to sit there and worry and say
how many of these are going to come back
how many of them do we lose permanently
how many did we lose permanently
because i left california to go to
dallas i lost you you know what the plan
was when i
left to california to go to dallas to go
back to california
to go back to california but california
has lost me yeah
california's last year all my friends
family everybody's in california
you can close my eyes put me in the car
open the window i can smell and tell you
what street we're on i've driven on
every single road in l.a in california
i mean you can tell me take me anywhere
i know how to go to
any place because i've been all over
california all over all right
so now i come here i've lost every other
day okay
i just know how to get to the office in
the airport when i'm in texas these main
ways are very different maybe
yeah exactly that's not enough it's a
youtuber so now you go to a different
place but that's a
permanent person you lost this is not a
temporary person
a permanent person with jobs they
created jobs you're okay losing
temporary people
for example when hurricane happens in
florida where do people go new york new
york
but it's temporary yeah so florida
doesn't care because like listen after
the hurricane
they're coming back of course when new
orleans hurricane hit
people left permanent right right right
yeah so yeah new york
places is this a permanent exodus
or is this a temporary one because if
it's permanent
new york's about to take a hit that we
don't even know the aftershock effects
of this you mentioned a few podcasts ago
a bunch of billionaires also
departed yes so not only the vacancies
are happening but you have job creators
and innovators 336 billion dollars of
wealth left that's a lot of money so
you know who's gonna have to do a lot of
cooking governor cuomo
come back to new york i'll cook you
dinner well you got cooking recruiting
about
15 16 000 people to cook